[Music]
after a summer grappling with ambulance
delays and record waiting times
it's about how we get a better flow
through the hospital system which is
something that benefits all patients in
what is likely to be his last few days
in the job the health secretary urging
the next prime minister to prioritize
nhs there's a very large number of
people working in roles that are not
patient-facing
and what i'm highlighting is that we
will bring much greater transparency to
those roles in the nhs that are not
working
in patient-facing roles so we can have a
better focus on is that the key priority
or are we better investing in things
that really impact on the patients we
don't make appointments at front desk we
have a triage system among the
priorities though bringing down gp
waiting times at surgeries like this one
in croydon every winter
for for years now
the nhs says we're going to face a hard
winter this year is no exception
especially with inflation and the energy
crisis these things have a huge impact
on general practice and if it has an
impact on general practice that's going
to ripple through the whole system
but it is images of ambulances queuing
outside amy that have laid bare the real
challenge for the nhs
people who've had heart attacks or
strokes in england this july wait an
average of almost an hour from an
ambulance
the nhs target is 18 minutes
in urgent calls the average waiting time
was more than three hours
the nhs and social care are deeply
intertwined patients are taking up beds
in hospitals because there isn't enough
space in care homes that means the next
cohort can't come in and that's when we
see ambulances queuing up outside
liz trust saying she wants to divert
some of the money from the nhs to social
care can the nhs afford that spending
one area has an impact on cost in
another so if for example there aren't
sufficient domiciliary care places then
that often means that someone stays in
the hospital much longer and that
manifests itself as a cost to the nhs so
my point is these are integrated so you
think it's right to take that money away
important that we're spending
what i'm saying is where they're
spending on social care that often would
have an impact on the costs in the nhs
he's unlikely to be in the job much
longer but today a warning for his
successor the nhs can't do everything
ally foreski sky news